you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
katanji brown jackson was confirmed by
the senate yesterday
and will become america's first black
woman to serve on the supreme court and
amy coney barrett has already tried to
touch her hair
oh how did she do that
wow
though
teach me about this if you don't get
your hands
i need to send her like a little fly
swatter yeah
that's right the supreme court of the
united states will include a black woman
as a justice for the first time in
233 years
that's right
for the first time in 233 years it's
just like that one episode of friends
president biden and judge katanji brown
jackson reportedly watched yesterday's
senate vote
together from the white house's
roosevelt room just like franklin
roosevelt would have hated
[Applause]
[Music]
the vote on judge jackson's confirmation
was held in the senate yesterday and
right after vice president kamala harris
announced the results a group of
republican senators walked out of the
senate chamber take a look
this brings us to a segment called where
you going
where you going
taking your racism and going home
hey where you going home to your wife
and your mistress
where are you going
is there a clearance sale at men's
warehouse
hey hey hey where you going
trying to catch that early bird special
at denny's
where are you going
you running home to make sure your
daughter isn't learning how to read
where are you going
are you going to get some denture glue
because all of your teeth fell out after
you were like a black woman has more job
security than me
look at that photo
so many backs and zero butts
even
even their exit is on the ones and
threes no
i'm not even there and i can tell that
this exit smells like mayonnaise where
are you going
are you going to try to dig up some dirt
on katanji brown jackson because she's
black didn't quite cut
it do you think this exit is making
people sad oh babies every room gets
infinitely more fun after you leave
they they waited til you left to pull
out the cake where are you on to the
right side of history
probably not this has been where you are
[Music]
forbes this week released its annual
list of the world's billionaires and
tyler perry is two of them
mother
favorite jokes yeah
absolutely outstanding
a notebook that belonged to i got i like
to take breaks from the monologue to
congratulate myself
later on tonight
that was a great joke
my husband will be like did you remember
yourself i'll be like yes i did
a notebook that belonged to scientist
charles darwin was recently returned to
cambridge university after going missing
in 2001 and everyone mentioned in it is
pissed
two disney brand hand sanitizers have
been recalled after the fda found that
they contained dangerous chemicals
officials became concerned after one
disney employee's hands swelled to 10
times their normal size
a news station in minneapolis recently
found footage from a segment in 1970
that showed singer prince when he was 11
years old and even then he still had
little tufts of chest hair
and finally a city in japan held an
annual celebration on sunday that is
known as the penis festival and i don't
know if it was a competition but in my
eyes they're all wieners
that was the monologue did you guys like
the monologue
good
the monologue likes yoto
guys
in other news scientists announced
recently that they have created a new
birth control pill for men that they
believe is 99 effective they also
believe the pill will have no side
effects here to give us his perspective
on this is the most progressive man in
the room
hi amber
thank you for holding space for me i
will do my best to make sure your voice
is centered and not mine
wow you are very progressive
so what are your thoughts on this new
birth control for men
oh i think it's a great idea women carry
so much of the burden when it comes to
contraception i'm glad that men are
finally going to be able to step up and
take some responsibility off their
partner's shoulders that's beautiful
i just want to do my part to help push
men past these outdated gender roles you
know good for you
as audre lorde said without community
there is no liberation
wow that is incredibly progressive so
you're going to take the pill
no
what i thought you were in favor of the
male birth control bill oh i am there is
no true freedom without reproductive
freedom and how can we expect only women
to shoulder the responsibility of
contraception when gender itself is a
construct so you're gonna take it no
way
you just said it was a good idea of
course it is because women deserve to
have agency over their own bodies amber
i'm one of the good guys so you're gonna
take it
i would rather die
you'd rather die than take a tiny little
pill yes i mean i don't know what that
pill is gonna do to my body or to my
mood but women have been taking birth
control pills for years and dealing with
all the side effects that come with that
and thank you and i stand with you
but at the end of the day i'm a man and
men are strong and this little pill
might give me a little headache
there is no proof of that right now it's
just been used on mice
i see well i'm learning and i'm growing
and i'm taking it all in and i'm seeing
you and i'm hearing you
thank you
but they tested that pill on mice and i
can't risk my junk turning into tiny
mouse junk
that's not a thing besides it's not even
on the market yet there's a chance it
might not even get approved oh well in
that case yes i will take the pill
do you mean that
no
but i'm listening the most progressive
man in the room everybody
now
i want to switch gears for a minute here
because
because i have my own show i have a
responsibility to say things that people
need to know that aren't being said it's
a cool opportunity that i don't take
lightly there are very big obvious
truths that no one wants to say on tv
but i will so
i can't believe i have to say this but
you matter even though florida passed
the don't say gay bill that prohibits
teachers from talking about gay people
in their classrooms you matter
children who are gay shouldn't sit in
school wondering if there are other
people like them they shouldn't be made
to feel like there is something wrong
with them and kids with two moms or two
dads shouldn't be made to feel like
there is something wrong with their
family there is nothing wrong with being
gay and cutting off an entire part of
our community will hurt us all in the
long run now they can stop us from
saying gay they can try to put all the
restrictions on you they want they can
try to get people to be scared of you or
grossed out by you and i'm sorry but it
doesn't change the fact that you matter
and another thing
i can't believe i have to say this but
stop selling luggage at the airport if
i'm at the airport i already have
luggage
you think i just showed up with some
loose t-shirts and a hundred dollars
you think i'm walking around with two
handfuls of socks like where can i put
these where can i put these
shut down that luggage store at the
airport and replace it with a store that
sells something useful like vodka
and i can't believe i have to say this
but
it is wrong for there to be hundreds of
new anti-trans bills being introduced
across america this year it is not okay
to make trans children feel unsafe they
deserve our protection but it's a lot
easier to get people to vote republican
by making up problems like immigrants
are taking our jobs or black people are
going to come get you and i'm so sorry
that our trans community has become the
latest boogeyman you deserve better and
you matter
also i can't believe i have to say this
but
don't play music out loud on public
transportation
i get that you can't wait till you get
home to listen to thong song by cisco i
get it the most but that doesn't mean we
all want to be magically transported to
1999 with you either buy headphones or
sit in silence and question your life
choices like a normal person
if you think it's fine to make us all
listen to your personal dj session
you're wrong we're wrong wrong wrong
i can't believe i have to say this but
think pieces about whether we should
teach school children about queer people
or gender identity are not okay
who you are should never be up for
debate the only thing those think pieces
make me think is that the person who
wrote them is a bigot
and finally i can't believe i have to
say this but
crocs are ugly
they look like colanders for your feet
they look like two little buckets that
lost a fight with a hole punch i cannot
believe someone tricked y'all into
wearing them
people are like nurses wear them because
they're comfortable well i think nurses
deserve better
i didn't bang on pots and pans every
night for nurses that have wet socks
that's not right
now i thought people were wearing them
because they cost a dollar but
do you know they cost more than a dollar
these cost 35
these cost 54.99
and these cost
625 dollars
man
for 625 dollars you can wear no shoes
hop on my back and i'll take you
wherever you want to go
so
there you go the don't say gay bill is
trash luggage should not be sold at the
airport you deserve to feel safe get
headphones we can see through your
hateful articles cracks and most of all
and i can't stress this enough you
matter
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you